chongqi and the legend of the ten rings
is finally in theaters worldwide like
any great marvel movie it works on
multiple levels with that in mind here
are a half dozen spoiler heavy lines in
shanxi that mean far more than you might
realize when you first hear them at one
point john john says i speak abc to
katie which many viewers might take as
just a cute way of saying i speak
english in actuality abc is an
abbreviation for american born chinese
writer director destin daniel [ __ ]
said just before the film's release at a
press event attended by looper our
conversation behind which languages
should be spoken was always rooted in
the logic of the characters that
conversation started in the writers room
and then once our actors came in it was
always a dialogue with them is this
character bilingual trilingual
quadrilingual characters could speak
whatever made sense at the time as for
the abc line simu liu who plays shanxi
said the exchange feels very real
explaining abc of course means
american-born chinese it's the first
time that you've seen in a movie someone
just calling that out but it's a lived
experience
early in the movie at an unguarded
moment when the characters are just
living their everyday lives we hear we
are living in a world where any minute
half the population could disappear this
line not only alludes to the wider mcu
universe with plot lines revolving
around thanos and his infamous snap but
also to the mindset of ordinary humans
still grappling years later with the
ramifications although chang chi and the
legend of the ten rings doesn't add any
new names to known victims of the snap
the event touched everyone and it does
make clear that it's still hanging over
the heads of every person on the planet
the general unease of the populace is
backed up by a support group poster that
can be glimpsed next to the door that
shawn enters when he's visiting katie's
family it reads post blip anxiety you
are not alone
the seemingly straightforward line give
me the pendant and no one gets hurt
represents the final moment of sean's
innocence for more than a decade he has
been working to build himself a new life
in san francisco one far away from his
chinese upbringing but as we're about to
see he hasn't been neglecting his
physical fitness when the robber makes
that statement sean could have just
handed over the jade pendant shrugged
his shoulders and katie would likely
think no less of him but that wouldn't
make much of a movie would it does he
look like he can fight come on bro
in a heartbeat shawn launches from
mild-mannered bus patron to full-on
shangqi pulling out acrobatic
environment embracing ass-kicking moves
that would make jackie chan sit up and
applaud in a matter of moments he
doesn't just shatter half the windows on
the bus but also his remaining anonymity
and any pretense of normalcy with friend
katie who watches the whole thing with
her jaw open before finally regaining
enough sense to hop behind the wheel and
drive the bus by the time the scene is
over everything has changed sean has
revealed himself to katie as chongqi his
old life has dragged him back in and he
must go to china to confront his past
also the city of san francisco has a
really big mess to clean up
movies have employed training sequences
for decades but it's another thing to
show and explain in raw detail how day
after day month after month year after
year you were raised to be a killing
machine at one point xiangchi says from
sun up to sundown i was taught every
possible way to kill a man some movies
have the hero adept in martial arts from
the get-go as if it's just something
they picked up others allude to the
training but don't truly depict the full
dedication it requires but by the time
you're finished hearing the tale of
shanxi's upbringing under the tutelage
of his father and the mysterious death
dealer you fully realize how he was able
to mow down those baddies on the bus
keep in mind for almost the entirety of
shanxi and the legend of the ten rings
chang-chi does not have even one ring in
essence he's an unpowered would-be hero
relying solely on his training to battle
a wide array of threats who have
everything from superpowers to at the
bare minimum a machete hand so yes xiang
chi is a trained killer and simulio is
talented enough to sell you on all those
years of training of course by the end
of the movie shanxi does come into
possession of the ten rings so just
imagine how powerful he'll be the next
time we see him in action
when when woo says america was terrified
of an orange some viewers in the
audience may have no clue what the
wearer of the ten rings is talking about
but here's what he's referring to
audiences buying tickets to iron man 3
in 2013 thought they were going to see
tony stark square off against arguably
his arch enemy in the comics the
mandarin like the orange instead they
got guy pierce's aldrich killian as the
man behind the man and ben kingsley as
trevor slattery a british actor
pretending to be the mandarin at the
time some loved the bait and switch
others were disappointed or even flat
out angry as the years went by a third
narrative became the loudest by teasing
a chinese character and instead giving
audiences a white one marvel seemed to
be perpetuating a shameful hollywood
tradition of co-opting and whitewashing
the asian experience marvel head honcho
kevin feige became determined to not
only address such concerns but take back
the mandarin which is why in 2014 marvel
released a one shot called all hail the
king which depicted a post iron man 3
trevor slattery in prison the short film
features a reporter telling slattery
that his portrayal has angered the ten
rings the terrorist group associated
with the real mandarin at the end of the
film the interviewer reveals his true
identity as an agent of the mandarin and
takes slattery prisoner there's somebody
who wants to meet you
don't know him
no
but you took his name
and now he wants it back
which brings us to chongqi when woo's
recounting of the story and the later
revelation that slattery has been held
prisoner ever since in the real
mandarin's dungeon basement
the advice given to katie when she joins
the battle at tallow if you aim at
nothing you hit nothing is more than
just archer mindset as we see at the
beginning of the film sean and katie
were leading a largely aimless existence
valet parking cars for low wages
spending nights drinking and singing
karaoke as katie's family were all too
eager to point out it felt like a road
map to nowhere but what she didn't
realize is that her drinking buddy did
in fact have a purpose even if he was
actively working to suppress it through
chongqi's embracing of his destiny and
her support as a loyal friend the two
characters ended the film with something
to finally aim for a future as
superheroes possibly as avengers and
perhaps katie continuing to embrace her
skills as an archer and car chase driver
if you hang around until the very end of
the credits you'll hear shaling say
let's get started we have a lot of work
to do indicating the donning of a new
day for the character for years her
father wen wu had forbidden her from
training forcing the young girl to
slightly study the men around her and
resolve to be even more effective in her
movements later in life she'd become
disappointed by another man when brother
xiang chi left her behind in china now
after the heroes won the day at talo and
her father is no longer a threat to
contend with chiang chi has taken the 10
rings and once again left this time for
a new life of adventure in san francisco
and the sanctum sanctorum this leaves
xia ling alone to rebuild and rule over
a new kingdom which is where we find her
in this end credit scene surrounded by
people training for battle where will
this new chapter take her it's hard to
tell because in the comics there is no
shaolin but shaolin could be based on
the cursed lotus a super villain who's
the older half-sister of chongqi in the
comics the cursed lotus was a gifted
hand-to-hand combatant and seductress
who longed to follow in her father's
footsteps and led her own criminal
organization called the oriental
expediters although there's an extremely
good chance that name will not be
appearing in the mcu it's possible that
the people we see training under her
tutelage are early expediters and as
we've already seen from shaolin's
prominence in the underground fighting
community she knows plenty of tough
folks who would likely be for hire we
almost certainly haven't seen the last
of shaolin and chongqi better be
prepared for another smackdown with sis
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite mcu movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]